Speaker 1: Tucker Carlson is now starting to
prepare his audience for what he believes is an
indictment of Donald Trump. That is coming. Now,
there's a couple of different reasons why Tucker
Carlson may be doing this. One of the reasons
may be that he is trying to soften the blow and
preemptively sort of deflate what may be coming
so that when it happens, he can say we knew this
was going to happen. This is that this is part of
the scam. It's part of the witch hunt, whatever.
Tucker Carlson seems to be pretty friendly
with Trump right now. You might remember that
a few weeks ago at this excuse me, Saudi backed
live golf tournament. Live the golf tournament
at Bedminster in I think it's Jersey. Tucker
Carlson and Marjorie Taylor GREENE and Trump
were photographed together hanging out. So Tucker
clearly has some kind of vested interest in this.
And he is now kind of just saying, as an
aside, the indictments coming. It's not
even if it's more of matter of what.
Speaker 3: You're going to see here,
that's the line. And no doubt Asa
Hutchinson and Mitch McConnell
and Dan Crenshaw and the rest of them
will be telling you the very same thing
when the Biden Justice Department or some
other state law enforcement agency under
their influence finally does what you know
they're going to do, which is indict Donald
Trump. Obviously, they're going to do that.
Speaker 1: So the point here is saying these
people are so biased, these people are so in
the tank against Trump, they are so viciously
determined to damage him that the indictment is
coming. But it's going to be a bogus indictment.
It's not going to be based on anything.
Speaker 3: Who knows how? Maybe they'll produce
surveillance video from our logo. Apparently,
they've already subpoenaed that. And we'll spend
the next year talking about how it shows
Trump mishandling classified information.
Really? On the summer. Remember the endless Russia
collusion hoax? We're in for a lot more of that.
Speaker 1: The Endless Russia collusion hoax
which led to 37 indictments and so many people
ultimately pleading guilty that it recovered more
money than it cost to run that investigation.
That's the witch hunt Tucker is talking
about. That's revisionist history.
Speaker 3: That's going to how Trump is a
criminal. And if you expressed any support
for him or any interest in retaining,
I don't know, the rights of free speech
and due process, you're a criminal, too.
Speaker 1: Now, of course, Trump's rights
of free speech have not been restricted in any way
by those investigating him. It is true that he was
banned by Twitter two years ago, has nothing to
do with the investigation, has nothing to do with
the First Amendment private company, with terms
of service, but that the Trump has been saying
whatever he wants and he can get interviewed
wherever he wants, at least in right wing media
anytime he wants. And in terms of due process,
all the I's have been crossed and T's dotted.
I know, as Sean HANNITY said last week, that.
Speaker 3: You are the threat. You're the threat.
And just mentioned you disagree with what
is happening is an attack on our government
their style. Just the other day after signing off
for the Mar a Lago raid, your Attorney General,
Merrick Garland, came on stage to whine about how
actually he was the victim. Here. He's the victim.
Apparently, some people disagreed
with the raid. So the FBI,
the most heavily armed domestic law enforcement
agency in the world, is now under threat from you?
Speaker 1: Well, yes, that is absolutely
true. There were death threats to FBI agents.
Gunmen showed up at FBI offices, including
in Cincinnati. Tucker is completely unhinged
and he wants us to believe that the victim here
is Trump. Trump's had his his free speech taken
away. No, he hasn't. Trump's had due process
denied. No, he hasn't. And it's really Trump
that is the victim. So there is the view from
Tucker. Tucker, who recently hung out with Trump
at his golf club. He is in a position to give
us a really honest and unbiased assessment.
Now, the other thing that I think is interesting
is the right seems to be talking much more about
an indictment than the left. And many on the
left are sort of resigned to a possible fate,
which is this isn't going to go anywhere in terms
of indictments. The right continues to say, oh,
they're going after this guy. I was looking
at the conservative subreddit the other day
and they're going on and on about how there's
a secret grand jury in D.C. that's imminently
going to indict Trump. Why are they starting
rumors about their own guy going down? Is it
a sort of negative visualization in the style
of the stoic philosophers? I don't think so.
Is it about diffusing the power of
the indictment when it eventually
comes? Because then it looks more like a plot
rather than actual justice and due process,
maybe. Or is it all to rile up the extremists so
that some of them commit the stochastic terrorism
that many of us fear is coming solely because the
possibility of violence may actually interfere
with the investigation. And when there is actual
violence, it's probably useful to many of the
people that are supporting Donald Trump globally.
To put it lightly, I don't know the answer,
but you're hearing a lot more indictment
talk from the right than from the left.
So there is Tucker's view, if you think
Tucker is able to fairly assess the situation,
that's his perspective, that an indictment
is coming, but it is a bogus indictment.